- [Instructor] What
we're going to talk about
in this video is how human activity
creates changes in the environment.
And not just any changes,
but changes that can disrupt an ecosystem.
And it can threaten the very
existence of some species.
And for the sake of this video,
we'll think about it in
five different dimensions.
The first is habitat destruction.
So this over here is a
picture of some trees
that have clearly been cut down.
And there's many reasons why trees
could be cut down like this.
One could be maybe
there's some logging here,
and we human beings, we do need wood.
Maybe it's being cleared for agriculture,
which we also need.
But when you do that, it's
clearly eliminating the trees
and many animals, many
different types of species,
were probably living in or
amongst or on those trees.
And if you do too much of that
they might not have anywhere to live,
or they might not have
enough places to live
to really thrive.
Now, another form of anthropogenic changes
or changes induced by human
activity would be pollution.
This right over here,
you can see the exhaust,
so to speak, from a
coal-fired power plant.
And that is polluting the air.
harmful chemicals are being released,
including greenhouse gases.
And that's going to have other effects
above and beyond just making
the air less pleasant.
But pollution isn't just about
harmful chemicals going into the air.
It could be about harmful
chemicals going into the water,
could be runoff from irrigation,
or some other type of chemical.
You could even have noise pollution.
And you might think of
that as an annoyance,
but it can actually disrupt
how certain animals behave.
In fact, it could raise the stress level,
which can change the biology
of animals in subtle,
but important ways.
Another dimension in which we humans
are affecting ecosystems
is by introducing species
to places where they might
not have been before,
especially what's often
called invasive species.
So this is a picture here of nutria,
oftentimes referred to as nutria rats.
I was born and raised in Louisiana,
and there are many nutria in Louisiana,
and they did not come from Louisiana.
They came originally from South America.
They were brought to the Gulf Coast,
to the Southern United
States, for their firs.
The demand for their firs did not keep up,
and these nutria escaped
and now they are everywhere.
And you might just, once again,
view that as an annoyance,
but they start overpowering other species.
They are competing with other
animals for the same food,
for the same niche in the ecosystem.
Nutria are also infamous
for eating the plants
that hold together the
soil and the wetlands.
And so the more that they do that
the more that that soil gets eroded.
And then you have issues
like habitat destruction.
You have fewer wetlands for other species.
Now another dimension
is over-exploitation.
So this is a picture here
of what's known as trawling,
where you take a big boat
and you have this huge net,
and you just, the boat goes while the net
is just grabbing all
the fish in the water.
And these dots here are all fish.
And actually it goes, extends out here,
'cause the net is bulging
outward like that.
And you can see it's a
very efficient method
of getting fish, but you could over fish.
If you take too many
fish out of the ocean,
you're not going to
have enough to reproduce
and keep the population going.
And even though you might
get a lot of cheap fish
very efficiently in the short-term,
in the long-term the fish might go away.
All of these, as you can imagine,
connect in many ways.
And a fifth dimension we could talk about,
although it's very related to pollution
and even deforestation, is climate change.
And the climate change that we are
most familiar with right now
is this notion of global warming,
which is occurring as
we have rising levels
of greenhouse gases, like CO2.
And those could be
released from things like
this coal-fired power plant
that we saw a few minutes ago.
But there's many other
sources of things like CO2
and there's other greenhouse gases.
But as we human beings
release more and more of this
into the atmosphere,
these greenhouse gases
trap more and more heat, and that,
over the longterm, increases
average global temperatures.
And that doesn't just affect temperature.
When you affect temperature,
it can affect rainfall.
It can affect wind patterns.
And as we see in this picture over here,
it can affect things like the
amount of sea ice we have.
Because if, on average, global
temperatures are increasing,
then water temperatures
could be increasing,
then you have more melting sea ice
in both the Arctic and Antarctic.
And then, for example,
in the Arctic where you have polar bears,
they would have less ice to
be on when they're hunting
the walruses or the seals,
or frankly just ice to be on to rest
from swimming in the water.
And that melting ice also can contribute
to rising sea levels.
And it's not just the melting ice
that's contributing to rising sea levels.
It's also that water has different density
at different temperatures.
And so as you have that rising sea levels,
that affects ecosystems around the planet,
especially ecosystems close to the water.
And one of the species that is
most impacted by that is human beings.
Most human beings actually live very close
to sea level near a body of water.
So as those sea levels rise
they will have a very profound impact
on a lot of animals, but
especially human beings.